last question today hey David do you
think any Republicans will challenge
Trump in the 2020 primary do you think
they would have any shot I think the
answer is definitely this is a
Republican presidency that is ripe for a
challenge from within I don't think that
they would have any shot I think that
the incumbent power of Trump is so
overwhelming that even though you might
have individual or you I think you will
have individual Republicans who
challenge Trump in the Republican
primary for 2020 I think that the
majority of Republicans would be too
scared to support anybody but Trump and
that whoever challenges Trump will have
absolutely no chance but I do think you
will see challenges to Trump yeah and I
think the problem that they would face
these other potential candidates is that
Donald Trump is just really good at
beating up on other Republicans like he
took down 16 Republican candidates one
by one when after their appearances when
after things that were thought of as off
limits before so if you talk about you
know like him against Jeff Flake or Ben
Sasse or John Kasich do they stand a
chance those guys no they don't it's
just not happened they would all be
better options I think although you
could make the case that early in the
Trump presidency I was sort of making
the case that Trump had mostly just
passed executive orders and thus if
someone like Mike Pence took over it
would be significantly more damaging
things have evolved when it comes to
that and I'm not saying anymore that
pence would necessarily be better or
worse Pence is like a uniquely horrible
figure who by the way we barely hear
anything from it seems he's doing a
pretty proactive job it's thing staying
out of out of the limelight but I think
at this point the damage that Donald
Trump has done to alliances around the
world to the institution of American
democracy that at this point it would
actually be better to have a moderate
Republican who would be successful in
getting their agenda through I think it
would be less damaging than Trump yeah
problem is Trump is too popular among
Republican voters yeah and if you see
these new campaign ads for people
running in these like Little House
districts or for Senate the in the
Republicans they're all they're all
hugging Trump trying to stay as close to
him as possible yeah so
I don't think those two things square up
you can't have one I agree the other I
agree and I think that there will be
unsuccessful challenges mounted to
Donald Trump's power now do you think
it's possible Trump will bail on running
for re-election is that do you think
that's at all possible only if the
Russia thing scales up and it looks like
Robert Miller has something really bad
on him and that he would go down in
disgrace anyway via impeachment or
resignation then he would probably just
take the best option out which is yes a
hey I'm in my mid 70s now I made America
great again now I'm gonna hand the reins
off to the Mike Pence he'll do it here's
basically the issue with that if
Republicans win in November Trump's not
getting impeached and that means he
would be free to run for re-election in
2020 if Democrats were to win in
November now the impeachment risk
becomes more real for Donald Trump and
maybe that would make him rethink
although there's another side to it
which is if you're a sitting president
you can't be indicted
unless you're impeached unless he's sure
he's getting impeached he can delay any
possible indictments by remaining
President of the United States yeah I
mean I think impeachment is a real
possibility because you just need a
simple majority in the House of
Representatives and it looks like that
will go blue where there's a good chance
that it'll go blue in 2018 and then you
need 2/3 of the Senate to convict him
yeah thirds that's 67 votes good luck
getting there
it's got to be Nixon esque and there are
people saying it is we will see if it
ultimately rises to that but back to the
question Trump will be challenged by
Republicans in 2020 but they will not
defeat him unless circumstances change
drastically like it turns out he shot
someone on Fifth Avenue I don't even
know again he even said that wouldn't
affect it I would do it maybe it would
we've got a great bonus show for you
today access to the bonus show by being
a david pakman show member you can sign
up at wwe.com or at patreon.com slash
david pakman show